[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
hello everybody welcome to episode six
of the joke world podcast today our
guest he's in town opening for dan soder
this weekend we have christoph gene
what's up dude thanks for having me
thanks for coming on the show man so uh
you're in town opening for soder side
splitters um that just happened thursday
through saturday how did you how was
that it was great yeah i was good size
players love that club sodas man yeah
super fun was that the first time you
were able to work with him no i had done
like a couple guest spots or maybe one
guest spot in orlando for him cool uh
before
and that was yeah that was dope too yeah
we should mention you're from orlando
yeah
orlando right now yeah orlando comic how
is um how is that seen in orlando yeah
it's pretty good you know like you can
get up most every night and there's a
couple great shows um
i would say it's like
strong for a small scene like a really
strong small scene there are a lot of
rooms there
yeah there's a decent amount of rooms
like um i mean as far as like showcases
there's not many but there's plenty of
mics and there's a few mics that kind of
feel like
it's that weird uh small scene thing
where like the open mics function as
showcases anywhere else where
or larger scenes will have like oh it's
all comics it's always all comics it's
like oh i've done mics where there's
35 human beings there yeah those take
[ __ ] forever
what this can take a while too when
there's 35 people on a mic oh no no i
mean like uh like 35 like audience
members like oh oh like just people who
went to this coffee shop coincidentally
and then they stay and watch the show
that makes sense which is like that's
how you meant a lineup because i know no
no that would suck some open mics you
can get 25 people that sign up yeah no
yeah definitely yeah no that sucks and
you get spot 22. yeah yeah at this point
i'm just not i just won't go yeah
i'm just like nah it's okay i'm not
gonna wait i'm not gonna wait two hours
to do five minutes for no one yeah or
like it starts at eight or whatever and
then it's 12 30. and you haven't gone
yet and the only people left are seven
other comedians no yeah it's like at
that point just don't go like i i don't
know like that that's all like whoever
runs it just needs to just make it two
minute sets too just [ __ ] it just yeah
to make it shorter so you've um
something that you
that i first saw you on was the the 15
second podcast literally is one of the
funniest things it's a real like between
two ferns kind of vibe in a way but also
like its own thing because it's like set
up perfectly for reels or kind of like
social like quick hitting yeah social
media yeah that's exactly what
happened it was me my friend joe jacks
wanted to start like a long form podcast
and we were talking about it and my
ex-girlfriend was there
and she was like we were saying like oh
like uh
you know let's do it shorter let's not
make it like you know
we're not joe rogan here let's not make
it that long let's make it like 30
minutes you know
and uh because people's attention span
sucks and then my girlfriend jokes she's
like make it a minute long you know just
like sarcastically yeah and i was like
that's a good idea i'll do that yeah
and then it ended up being like 15
seconds
um
that's cool because you could still have
like if you wanted like a 30 minute or
an hour long podcast you could still do
that because the 15 second podcast at
least to me as a consumer of it is
almost like its own little like bit like
yeah it's because it's not like a no
it's not a podcast no it's just a sketch
it's just like a sketch series
yeah so you could do both almost yeah no
yeah definitely no we me and joe have
done
we were doing like long form podcasts
but he got uh he's been like i'm cancer
treatment stuff so he's [ __ ] he's out
of commission dude yeah yeah it's just
being real lazy with this gmo [ __ ]
that's unacceptable yeah he needs to get
off his ass dude yeah he's always
bitching about it constantly i want to
lazy yeah he's like i'm nauseous my
skull hurts it's like dude we gotta
report over us literally yeah like
you've had cancer for a year like how
people need to hear
yeah our [ __ ] our silly [ __ ] yeah like
where are the silly bits it's almost
like he has no perspective on what's no
it's like do you want a career like
what's your plan yeah like you need
content like we need content god i'm
visiting him in the hospital going
where's the content
yeah but uh yeah so that's good i i love
the if the 15 second podcast on it is it
just on instagram or is that it's on
instagram i put it on like youtube
shorts and um tick tock and stuff but it
really just performed best
on instagram for whatever reason um
yeah i kind of stopped making them
a while ago just because i kind of ran
out of ideas for them yeah i just and i
kind of forced out a couple and i'm like
not super happy with those honestly
i think they're still decently funny but
the first like 20 i made i was like hell
yeah like i got so many ideas for this
and then the next five i was like oh i'm
kind of like
pushing this idea too far and i'm like
i'm not gonna make something that just
you know
it's contrived or whatever and it also
kind of depends on what who the guest is
yeah because i also ran out of open mic
as i like you know this is like in
orlando i i'm out of open micros i think
yeah cool
so if you watch this and you're in
orlando open micro and you weren't on it
it's because i do not like it
i just want to make that clear
if you're like
you're a tampa guy i mean if you want to
make the the producer he's a tampa comic
and he's like you didn't have me on he's
just being a baby um i mean if you think
of an idea dude let me know because i'm
i'm done now yeah people come to me
i'm not i'm not even creative anymore
um i'm outsourcing my creativity yeah
that's the real that's when you make it
it's outsourced all your writing that's
true something that i think is creative
that i've seen you do is like the uh the
street reaction or the on the streets
yeah the snapchat stuff yeah so is that
it's because it's also on your pages and
stuff but it's on it's like a snapchat
discovery show yes how did that kind of
come about snapchat were you already
doing it and snapchat hit you up and
it's like i like
uh there's just like a production
company that was based in orlando that
was doing like man on the street stuff
and they dm'd me and they were like oh
they saw the 15 second podcast and then
we're like do a man on the street thing
for us and i was like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah uh so
started doing that and then and they're
great because i can post clips of it on
my own social
and so it's so easy like they have an
editor they have a camera guy i just
[ __ ] show up
they do [ __ ] everything other than
than like i'd come up with the questions
and i asked them and then i'll edit the
clips but it's like
if the editing's done i just [ __ ]
clip it and put subtitles on it
so that's great i didn't realize that
was yeah it's perfect such a nice thing
like because it's four or five minutes
every week
and it's four or five minutes of stuff
that i just make so that's really been
really great how do you come up with a
so for people that might not be familiar
you are
um you have like a little table on the
street yeah streets of downtown orlando
i'm assuming like a a party scene party
street and um you're kind of sitting
there with your microphone and then just
random drunk people will come up and
you'll ask them the question uh it could
be you know would you rather or
say something that you have you haven't
told your parents or something yeah yeah
yeah
some good question to ask a drunk person
yeah yeah so how do you uh how do you
write this do you just go find other
drunk people and start interrogating
them
i mean the goal is like so you need to
like have like a
title for the episode and i'm just
trying to make it enticing so just
trying to think of like questions that
want that people want to be answered or
like that people see and they think of
their own response and so
they're curious what other people say
you know something you know like that's
uh attention grabbing not you know full
on click bait but like you know in that
sounds like clickbait yeah yeah i mean
like well it's like i guess it's not
even click bait though because like i
guess i don't know it depends on you
it's not clickbait because you are
asking i'm asking them and they actually
do it you know it's not like psych it's
not really like that which happens all
the time with clickbait where you know
you see the art the title of the article
is like
a [ __ ] uh guy almost dies maybe does
he die yeah then you read it he's like
he didn't even come close not even he's
yeah it was like actually fine a story
that happened like 30 years ago yeah
yeah no it's like garbage yeah so at
least you know there's some integrity in
our clicks i see on snapchat there's so
much like click bait like regarding like
sports and [ __ ] it'll be like like
lebron james traded to a chinese
basketball team
like no didn't happen yeah why are you
guys even trying it's like some chinese
guy was like i'd like this to happen and
then lebron was like no yeah and then
that's the story and you're like oh
thanks
awesome and snapchat's like
yeah and then you watch it and then you
see six ads to get to the end of the
five minute video and then you're like
what i like god damn it dude
yeah no [ __ ] that you know
um i get so mad yeah yeah this
clickbait's annoying as hell but uh
but i do like your show not that not
that that's clickbait yeah
but i think we're you know if the
question will be like uh you know how
long should sex last like i think that's
like an enticing thing yeah and then
people click on it and they're like oh
you know they're like i'll [ __ ] for 25
years you know yeah they click through
and then some guys like an hour and he's
like that's not long enough [ __ ]
i'm trying to just be entertaining right
is there um is it like
any particular things you remember of
just uh
good good nights doing that of like the
the crowd was was hot the people were
were funny like i'm sure there's some
duds in there that come in and have
really yeah i mean if you yeah it really
depends like sometimes
we can't make filming on a weekend
because like i'm booked in wherever the
[ __ ]
you know or the producers like i'm
filming something in miami this you know
so we have to film on like um
thursday or sunday and it's like just
not as good
and uh people aren't that drunk and we
can't stay out that late you know [ __ ]
so that always ends up being
for five minutes it takes us three hours
to get something to get enough people
who are like
you know drunk or funny
and
but friday saturday we can be out there
for three hours and we'll have two to
three like
in the can like it really just depends
on like yeah like halloween was great oh
yeah halloween was awesome around st
patrick's day was really good and you
know like if we had been around cinco de
mayo that would have probably been sweet
yeah like just any kind of like drinking
holiday you know this is probably going
to be awesome that's awesome you should
come down for like gasparilla gasparilla
would be good what's that february yeah
or uh
when we win the cup here soon that would
be
that's true that is a good idea that's
good drinking yeah where are we at with
that two follow hockey it's uh
series it's the second round and the the
lightning are up 2-0 okay and the
florida panthers game threes tonight so
if they win that
they will be in one more round and then
after that after that
stanley cup is best of five
seven best of seven series all these are
best of seven series
hockey and bass er and basketball
playoffs are so long i know it's like
well
yeah yeah it's like
doesn't it kind of inflate the value of
playoffs um i think that the mba at
least is starting to really inflate
their value playoffs because they're
getting more teams into it and they're
like half the league makes the playoffs
and that yeah right is wrong half the
league makes the playoffs yeah it's like
why are there they're not then why are
we doing playoffs yeah yeah no it's
stupid that's stupid then that's just a
tournament then that's just like an end
of the season tournament that makes no
sense yeah it doesn't it doesn't add up
and football the nfl playoffs is so
exciting because like there's nothing
else can go to the super bowl somehow
you just gotta win one game right if the
bengals had to win a seven game series
they would
[Music]
yeah it's crazy by the end of like the
month would just be yeah five you know
five dead bangles yeah they all have the
cte by the end of the year
i mean they
is cte and like
domestic abuse
that's just yeah
that's just living in the north i guess
so do you uh
do you follow uh
uh not a hockey guy do you follow uh any
other sports i mean i'm kind of into
baseball but not super
yeah deep into it i'll just watch like
a lot of youtube baseball content right
i get sucked into like and it's stuff
that's like
it's like the youtube equivalent to 30
for 30. just these like mini sports
stocks that's pretty interesting though
yeah it would be like what happened to
yasiel pleague in
cuba and i'm like i don't know yeah tell
me but if you were like what happened
who's like favored to win
or who's gonna go make the playoffs this
season you think i'd be like i have no
idea okay i don't know so you're like
you're into the stories yeah i guess i'm
kind of into the stories or i'll just
watch like highlights or like i don't
know the other day i was looking up i
was like how many pitches are there like
how many kinds of pitches that's a
really good question are there and then
i realized there's really only like
three
main kinds
yeah it's like fastball change a
breaking ball like and then you can
break those up like you have a splitter
that's still a fast ball really you have
uh a two-seam that's a fastball
four-seam that's a fastball and then
actually knuckleball is the only one i
forgot but uh there's four kinds and
then breaking balls like slider slurve
curve fork ball screw you know there's
like yeah they kind of break up but
they're all kind of the same with slight
yeah it's worth six curve it's like yeah
it's mainly fastball change up uh
curveballs it's so strange for someone
to get like so technical into
part of a sport that they just don't
have
yeah i don't even really i don't watch
games yeah i'll look up scores sometimes
or like watch highlights of the rays but
i don't i'm not going to sit and watch a
baseball game right like i'll go to i
want to go to a baseball game go to a
baseball game that'd be sick i love
going to sporting events yeah like i
went to like an orlando city soccer game
like i'm not a huge soccer guy but i
like soccer and i'm like this is lit i
love this it's so fun but watching it on
tv i'm like yeah yeah it's whatever i
would never watch a full unless it's
like the world series i don't think i'd
ever watch a full baseball game it's so
slow it's so crazy slow so it yeah but
if you make like a night out of it make
a day out of it just [ __ ] like have a
couple of food drinks like yeah spend 14
on a hot dog yeah that's so nice
that would rule i love that i love when
i when going to emily for a lightning
game and it's like here's one tall boy
for sixteen dollars like this is awesome
it's crazy i would have sucked to buy a
whole case for this thing yeah i'm so
glad yeah i don't know there should be
some sort of law that prohibits
like
uh
like uh what's the word like location
based
you know because it's like they got you
yeah it's like you're all right right
right don't let you bring it in
it's like going to the movies and you're
like or like an amusement park it's a
yeah movies amusement park
[ __ ] sporting events concerts it's
like dude
[ __ ] you so much yeah you just pissed me
off the second i'm like i'm just trying
to see you know whatever whatever band i
like it's it's absurd and like bars
don't even do that and bars have you
right where they want you too
you know more than anything well there's
actual competition there it's like oh
what are you are you gonna go see you
know stone age somewhere else like what
are you going to [ __ ] do about it
[ __ ] you yeah it's like you want a drink
yeah you want to drink then do you want
to see the new nic cage movie yeah or
not dude go [ __ ] yourself that's a
[ __ ] that's an eight dollar we have
nick cage you don't yeah yeah exactly
they just got you right by the balls
dude god i'm just it just makes me want
to just [ __ ]
[Music]
go full communist full neck cage just
just become a communist yeah dude and in
communist countries all their beers are
the same yeah they're all the same where
you go you go no matter where he goes
if you go to see a nick cage movie in a
communist country you know popcorn is
the same price as if you bought it at a
supermarket the story might be a little
different they might yeah yeah they're
gonna edit
they're gonna edit the movie yeah maybe
a little propagandized but i'll take
that for the uniformity of price and as
long as nick cage is still in it yeah
i'm not gonna completely crop them out
you know yeah that's why i
okay i'm done with the cage but
i was going to try to keep going it was
a good place
but places that places that like to rape
you on prices like amusement parks
you're in the capital of amusement parks
maybe in the country yeah yeah yeah do
you from do you frequent any of those
did you when you when you
at any time in your life no no no i
worked at universal for a while and i
really did not like it i was it's
miserable i mean i was like a cashier so
it's gonna talk no matter you know i
mean unless you're a cashier at some
place you love which i can't imagine but
they were like [ __ ] dorks he like
loved universal even if you love
somewhere being a cashier is just yeah
it just sucks but they're like it's all
worth it because i get free tickets like
you're a [ __ ] you are a [ __ ] you
have a hole in your brain that's you got
to stay away from the anyone that's so
excited about
like you you're so stupid yeah
yeah dude and they would like they're
like i remember on the first day some
lady was like are you going to go like
on the rides on your lunch break and i'm
like [ __ ] what i like how this lady
has a list yeah i mean definitely
she had a lisp you know she definitely
did like you're gonna go on the
universal right
i'm like no like we got a half hour for
lunch yeah i'm like i'm gonna eat yeah
are you gonna you're gonna go on the
ride instead of eat are you gonna stand
in line for the whole lunch hour yeah
yeah she's like we don't get uh
you know we don't get discounts on
turkey legs but i love them so much and
i'm like
but i love them so much
get away from me yeah you're gross
there's so you always hear about disney
adults are there universal adults yeah
there's the same thing that's weird
that's weird
i think it's because
disney has like a specific hold on
people's childhoods yeah
like universal's like you know there's
like some spider-man [ __ ] and there's
like the hulk and this is like
yeah so it's not like it's not like um
you know aladdin which is yeah or it's
not like making every girl's dream come
true yes but also like harry potter for
some people is like that there's some
weirdos about harry potter true there is
like and i feel like you could be one of
them
yeah [ __ ] that maybe it's because you
might look i've never seen them but i
feel like you look like the character
like all the characters
thank you dude i appreciate that like
hermione and i could be hermione and
ron's kid with the glasses yeah yeah
you're all just dude i'm harry's you're
not into harry potter though no i don't
give a [ __ ] about him
dude nice i didn't read the books as a
kid [ __ ] her yeah [ __ ] harry potter the
boy who's jizz dude
i don't even know without reference
because that's how i live
i don't even know i mean all the movies
are fine you know what i mean i never
read the books i'm sure they were great
if i was like eight and i got into it
but i just didn't right i was not a big
reader
yeah everything kind of sucks
no i like reading now and like uh but
when i was a kid i just didn't really
read like that to be honest my only
experience with harry potter growing up
was we had these ar tests so like oh
yeah yeah you read that and then bigger
books got you more ar points right
because you got a bunch of points like
they gave you some like pizza party yeah
yeah yeah
and so
and it's so funny looking back how like
awesome pizza parties were and it's like
this cost them 25 years
changes our [ __ ] life yeah in that
moment but i i was like pizza party
um
or not pizza party ar points harry
potter was like the got you like 40
points or something because a thick book
and so i took all the ar tests for the
harry potters but i didn't read them
because i'm not a nerd obviously yeah of
course and i i don't think i got any
points of them because i failed all of
them but like just based on the
questions i kind of picked up some
things about like characters names
you're like i basically yeah so i failed
to quit so then i went to universal for
the first time this october for like
their uh haunted house kind of thing
yeah with my girlfriend i hated it yeah
i hate hanukkah
what is it uh
what the [ __ ] is it called halloween
horror nights right yeah yeah i guess i
blacked out yeah she loves
stuff no oh okay oh you're so scared no
i wasn't actually because we only went
in one haunted house because that's how
scared i was oh my god we drove all the
way there she was so excited about it
and that we went in one haunted house
because dude i i don't like it yeah but
we went on some of the rides it was fine
but anyway we went to the harry potter
world and it seemed like it was really
cool like set up like very realistic and
detailed and i was like man i i bet if i
was in the harry potter like i would
think this is great yeah but since i'm
not it just looked like a bunch of like
pacey kids in robes like waving sticks
around yeah yeah yeah it's like who
gives a [ __ ] yeah no it's not for us no
it's not for us because you're 24 yeah
i'm 26.
we're just white dudes yeah i assume
you're a white dude i am okay you could
have been like a puerto rican or
something but nice dude no one's ever
said that to me before well i mean maybe
half puerto rican yeah now i'm just like
greek or something wow
i'm on a high horse now i don't know why
i just saw what's your last name from
bach oh you're german yeah oh yikes um
i think this is an alt-right nazi
podcast
that's what i agreed to do but yeah i
thought you knew just based off my first
message
um
what was i talking about i don't even
remember
oh it's not for us it's not for yeah
it's for women and children right you
know the main wizards which is why it's
so good it's because those are the
people who buy things or are like
motivated like we don't buy i don't know
about you but i don't buy anything right
compared to a woman compared to like a
kid who's like seasoned and it's like oh
[ __ ] you know and then like you ever go
to like a department store to get you
get clothes right right the men's
section
is like a [ __ ] it's like it's like a
10 by 10 foot
area in the back you have to find it you
have to find it yeah you like walk
through a sea of women [ __ ] at a macy's
to get to the men's yeah like there's a
reason for that because women buy [ __ ]
and dudes don't right like we're like i
have my shirt i have my yeah i have my
shirt why would i go get another shirt i
have my shirt what do you mean
this is my shirt yeah exactly
so yeah exactly so like if you go to
like some consumerist place or whatever
like some
thing like universal or disney it's like
it's for women it's for children it's
for and then the dudes are there because
they have families like they're not
there on their own if they are they're
[ __ ]
weird
if you like
dudes bachelor party yeah yeah can you
imagine yeah all the bros
universal like it's not come on yeah
we're going to universe we're also going
to [ __ ] vegas yeah yeah yeah yeah
what is that what are you going to do
it's like yeah let's get [ __ ]
butterbeer bro like you're like what
what in the world is going on let's see
what family we belong to what is that
the
house yeah dude it's basically you know
it's candy
roller coasters and likes fizzy
sweet cocktails like who is that for
that's for kids it's not for dudes it's
like it's not for the bros unless you're
a pedophile though that'd be yeah
exactly and that's understandable at
least right if you were a pedophile
maybe dude yeah
i mean that just that would be way less
weird if you
were a pedophile yeah in there
yeah it would explain why you were there
in fact if i see a guy by himself in
there i'm gonna just get yeah it's a
pedophile yeah probably they're usually
just dorks dude it's just like
there's i don't know it's like uh it's
sad it's a sad state of affairs really
and i think the la like talking about
buying stuff in general the last place
maybe a department store or the mall the
last place i'd ever buy something is a
gift shop after like a roller coaster
yeah roller coaster it's miserable it's
like you walk in and there's like here's
a pez dispenser or a key chain with your
name on it yeah good luck finding one
and then it's going to be yeah 16 yeah
you're like oh my gosh they have one
with my name
oh my god yeah doesn't that make you
feel like a nothing doesn't make you
feel like you aren't even real but then
you get so like i used to get so excited
finding one that said jacob and it's
like hey by the way you have the most
popular basic names like why is this
exciting yeah dude oh [ __ ] you take old
[ __ ] i can't look they have mine
yeah
yeah or like uh my family when we we
would go to
family vacations when i was little to
disney from all the way from
ohio it made more sense we were a family
whatever but we'd always do the pennies
like press the penny thing into the so
you're you're giving that made no sense
to me looking back you're giving them
money it's just a penny but then don't
you have to pay extra for yeah i think
it's a dot you put a dollar and a penny
in and then they press it like they make
a and the penny's no good anymore
yeah dude
you're pissed
you're like where's my penny there you
go you you guys ruined my [ __ ] pack
yeah dude what the hell it's got like an
elephant on it now from busch gardens or
whatever the [ __ ] busch gardens is a is
a tampa museum park i've never been to
but i i've heard of
that one's like just roller coasters
there's no it's just like africa themed
vaguely okay it's like there's like an
egypt thing and then there's like a
safari part you know it's called busch
gardens bush guards is after beer
yeah because it sounds like it'd be like
like the upper deck of like uh like yeah
of a baseball stadium
yeah yeah
hillary never left the bush gardens
there is something like that at ray
stadium i believe but a tropicana the uh
the main amusement park where i'm from
is cedar point and that is just like
roller coasters like like it's like
thrill-seeking like roller coasters like
loop-de-loops up and down and there's
really no like
theme to it i respect the hell out of
that it's just a carnival not even a
carnival it's just like aggressive well
i guess that is where carnival is i mean
there's no like it's not like oh it's
africa or no yeah all universal whatever
you know ip yeah it's just like get on
these roller coasters it's like just for
people that love roller coasters
so that
that i can respect a little bit more
at these theme parks
no it's funny the idea of them being
like what do guys like jake think you
know it's like they don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude like you would go there you
would buy a ticket and nothing else yeah
dude yeah like i don't know i just hate
spending money i hate spending money
especially additional money because you
already paid for the thing and then you
get in oh my god dude yeah you drop like
several hundred on yeah just getting
there and getting in and then they're
like oh by the way you're [ __ ] on the
price of everything else and the parking
oh yeah it's a it's a nightmare it's a
it's a misery yeah like i already feel
like a crotchety
old man
like father you know i feel like i'm in
my mid 40s and i'm just like i [ __ ]
hate it
this is miserable this is for my dumb
ass kids
yeah
they suck but i hated working that was
the point if you think about even what a
rollercoaster really is it's just like
see like cte
sit down and let us just jostle yourself
yeah yeah just wrestle your brain around
dude there was a um just recently there
was some kid at a carnival
that was like over the weight limit yeah
that was in orlando oh really yeah he
died wow yeah yeah that was [ __ ] yeah
no like they didn't put his harness on
correctly or it just i don't know
exactly what happened
but
i saw the video of it which is horrible
don't watch the video of it it's
all right we're putting the video in
right now
and we're going to take a quick break to
watch a video
link in the description
if you want to see the fun spot death
yeah that's your new compilation series
on joke world yes
there's like is people dying
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] all this like stand up
come on let's talk about it
who gives a [ __ ] yeah what we're doing
now is compilations now that i have this
audience hostage
yeah you've garnered enough subscribers
you can show them the content that you
want yeah
dude welcome yeah welcome to the live
league podcast it's literally half of
what your mom's house is
that's true that is literally your mom's
house
yeah it's just
giggling that isis
danny brown's cackling at
uh some kid falling off a [ __ ] oh
that's zip line or whatever the hell the
danny brown show i uh i saw some clips
of that that's pretty interesting i love
danny brown as a rapper i've not watched
his podcast
that tom has put up and it seems obvious
that it's kind of a thing to like just
expand that your mom's house reach into
a completely new demo yeah i mean he
loves podcasts and he loves comedy like
he was on kill tony and stuff like he's
like way into it i remember seeing like
an old
old clip of him being interviewed by
some comic or something danny brown and
him saying like
oh like you know i want to be a stand-up
if i wasn't rapping you know
because he is like a silly funny guy
yeah no the clips are funny yeah it's
just it's very smart of because your mom
says it's a network they have like a
bunch of different shows obviously yeah
they hit an entire different demo of an
already a super savage rapper who has
half a million followers already
i mean oh yeah it makes sense for
everybody dude he's like twitch
streaming dude he's like all over like
he's like pretty smart with his like
media yeah i don't know if i would have
liked just gaming yeah i didn't really
expect that
i like i i don't think i've heard much
from
david brown at all yeah or really any
rappers in in that space i mean there's
a t-pain does that he plays games yeah
like t-pain also um
he it was he yeah he's the one that was
that's becoming a comedian too right
no no no no that's ti ti ti di
that's not going well being a [ __ ]
menace to the atlanta open mic scene for
no reason at all didn't he he called out
some some girl and
well yeah i mean he was like she like
made fun of him or something i don't
remember the exact context but like um
she made fun of him and then he like
called her a [ __ ] like from the crowd
and then she like doubled down went
really hard on him because
you know comics have a
penchant for for being able to do that
and like yeah of course like don't don't
try to make me the best she has the
ability to do that yeah it's just brand
new yeah he's just some guy like he's
as far as stand-up because he's just
some guy and he has [ __ ]
like can you imagine if i had if you got
heckled and you knew the guy had sexual
assault allegations right it's just a
layout like you're just gonna dump that
down like that's just such a game like
from like from an audience members yeah
yeah if they're being a [ __ ] and
then you know what the guy is sexual
assault it's like what are you gonna not
use that the guy's being addicted
exactly so yeah she just [ __ ] was
like yo [ __ ] you dude you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] rapist
and it's working for her and he got
really upset yeah he also i heard just
would run the light like just do 30
and bomb that's not going to be good no
no he sucks at kind of somebody like
he's not i've never seen ti in anything
and been like man that guy's that guy
seems funny all right like danny brown
would be scary funny yeah like there's
some rappers who seem like funny people
yeah um for sure i'm trying to think
other ones i feel like mac miller was
funny oh mac miller definitely was funny
one of my favorites people say jack
harlow seems funny but i have a vendetta
against jack harlow no i don't i don't
like him as a as an abstract idea but i
don't know anything about him yeah i
barely have listened to his music
frankly well what i i thought he was
fine enough yeah until
and this actually involves orlando
like two months after moving here yeah
um
me and my roommate
my roommate had already lived here for
like a year but i went to college with
him we're good pals whatever so one of
his friends they already had around here
was like hey do you guys want to go to
this jack harlow concert yeah it's in st
pete and we're like
and she's like i really really love jack
carla i want to go and we're like all
right it's insane pete it's on a tuesday
yeah fine we'll go 15 minutes away
whatever 30 minutes away so then she
buys the tickets and then right after
goes oh
oh [ __ ] i accidentally bought these for
orlando on wednesday damn
and and she calls they won't give her a
refund but she already bought four right
and the girl's roommate was gonna be our
dd so we're like all right whatever now
we have to drive to orlando but at least
we have a ride there a ride back we're
gonna go we're gonna go see this concert
go see orlando and then we're gonna come
back the same night yeah we have stuff
going on you know like it's wednesday
yeah so we're like this is really
annoying now yeah drive an hour but
whatever
so
we go to the concert drive we drive to
orlando concert's not great but it's
fine yeah yeah yeah like whatever you're
not a jack harlow fan who gives a [ __ ]
but i am a rap fan sure so i'm like they
keep rap concert yeah yeah yeah but then
it was like not the best but it was not
like
i wouldn't have been like so mad that i
went but yeah what didn't
my dick was still attached to my body
after like it didn't
so i
we go out to a bar after get a quick
drink
our driver the girl's roommate the girl
that we know her roommate
she apparently knows some guys in
orlando or something she's our
designated driver she is sober we're out
at a bar we're about to leave after it's
maybe
one in the morning
the producer's locked up
yeah i'll go again
all right and we're back and we're back
and we're back and we're back the
producer locked himself out try to just
stay in the in the in the yeah what were
you doing did you have to [ __ ]
he was [ __ ]
anyway long story short this this girl
that our driver we're all trash except
for our dd she knows some people in
atlanta these guys she goes hey i'm
actually going to go hook up with this
guy stay at this guy's house tonight you
guys need to it's like 1 1 30 in the
morning yeah you i she's like i'm going
to california for like two months after
this so like i just want to say goodbye
to my friends and
it's like first of all you're going on a
vacation like you don't have to say
goodbye
and then second of all dude like we are
more than committed at this point to you
taking us we are in orlando
hammered yeah and it's the middle of the
night
what
she's like so then my my roommate
after all this is going on he kind of
raised his voice a little bit he's like
what what are you talking about yeah
completely justified right and then
she's like don't [ __ ] talk to me
she's like i'm obviously going to help
split the uber we're like okay
this is the uber
tampa yeah so and it like now it's
the 2am i'm the time keeps coming back
now it's 2 a.m yeah somehow somehow i'm
so drunk i don't even think i did this
part
some guy comes to pick us some uber
comes to pick us up yeah it was like 130
and
i'm in the car
no it's not bad especially split by four
people but honestly that girl should
have paid the whole thing no no yeah
yeah because she
literally [ __ ] us like literally no
reason yeah and i was in the car the
whole time like talking to the driver
like dude doesn't this suck
you're doing this and my roommate was
like stop saying this
i'm like dude i can't believe you're
doing this yeah this is [ __ ] insane
so now every time i hear jack harlow his
song anything about him yeah i hate him
yeah it's like when a food makes you
sick
i'll never eat this again exactly and it
wasn't really his fault
but it's not at all his fault it's
nothing to do with jack hart he has
i saw the beatles and michael jackson
yes
yeah i gotta buy a [ __ ] i mean i
would think
that uber would be way more i know i was
not that expensive maybe it was more you
know for this okay for the story it was
like six hundred fifty dollars really
yeah
no i'm making it dramatic oh oh never
mind we're gonna splice that back up it
was like 600
because yeah because i mean like
130 for what a two hour hour and a half
drive it was only an hour for us but for
the guy oh it was an hour drive maybe
hour 15. yeah i guess it's
completely middle of the night no
traffic
hour 15 still only 130 dollars like so
i'm if i'm driving uber
and then i gotta drive back yeah that
guy has to go back and there's no chance
that there's someone in tampa like oh
this this [ __ ] left me yeah yeah yeah i
gotta go back to orlando yeah it's like
that's two and a half hours driving
how much gas is that that's like 50
bucks worth of gap right i mean
yeah this was a few months ago so it was
significantly cheaper it seems like
everything everybody's 20 30 bucks are
you still making 100 bucks for two and a
half hours work i guess that's pretty
good
never mind but the math checks out yeah
but still like such a pain in the dick
though pain in the dick to be driving at
that late at night late at night for
that long that long and with like that
half the time there's three hammered
people in your car and one of them keeps
saying how much this sucks
this is suck ass i can't believe you're
doing that maybe could be your next um
snapchat show is yeah the uber driver
the drunk i feel like there's some it's
gotta be yeah that's a pretty good idea
though yeah if you were an uber driver
and i know you spoke english then you
could
if there's like a good enough
i think there already is that there's a
lot of that content online of like uber
driver compilations of like
stupid drunk people
like yeah it's almost be like that show
uh cash cab
not cash cab but uh
cash cab is a good idea too just steal
cash cab
um we're redoing cash cash yeah it's the
the
i don't even know what the
i'm trying to think of another
alliteration for like uber or lyft um
rideshare lucrative lift
or whatever oh yeah
like something like that yeah but anyway
you do that you steal it from ben bailey
who's a comic i don't know if you knew
that oh really yeah
yeah cash type guy he's funny that's one
of his bits is just he's screaming
but he's like he was like in comedy with
like patrice and stuff like wow he did
like there's old
audio of like the roast of patrice and
ben bailey's stuff is good and he has
like an album that's pretty good i'll
have to check that out shout out bailly
underrated in the stand-up game yeah
definitely
rated in in the cab yeah properly rated
in the in the yeah in the game show car
game uh one of the best i'd say probably
he's on my mount rush
yeah arguably the best ever to offer
money for trivia in a car
that would be a fire show i bet it
already exists but like if you were a
purpose and you probably have to get so
many agreements with uber and lyft and
stuff or maybe right
of like
purposely
with microphones like you pass back two
mics to the people in the back and
there's like lights and [ __ ] and you're
like
kind of the same thing yeah that's a
cool shot or do you just do
i bet that exists there's already
compilations of like oh crazy uber
person it's usually like negative [ __ ]
yeah it's usually like some guy punches
you in the face oh yeah or someone just
won't get out of your car something dark
in this neighborhood if you know what i
mean yeah oh yeah awkward facial uber
yeah compilation or people that are like
just like a old lady that's out of her
mind and the person's like get out of my
car yeah yeah calling the police and
they're like i am like just like you
touched my breasts and i was like no i
didn't no i didn't have a camera here
yeah
she's like filming you now you're like
we're all filming each other
i love those i love karen videos yeah
and honestly the
term and the word it kind of makes me
cringe a little bit karen now it's funny
yeah i don't it's just like it's not a
punch line
that's the worst thing
overused
i just think it's a little cringy of a
of an adjective but the c i love i can't
look away to like a good grocery store
freak out oh yeah like
i just love it it's awesome it's yeah
it's just like i can't
i can't ever imagine myself being in
this this
space like like i'm so pissed off i mean
maybe maybe in a righteous way you know
yeah could be righteous i don't think so
though they're usually
yeah no they're not the whole point is
that they're dead wrong yeah and like
stupid about it stuff that i care about
i've i don't feel like i ever could
react that's wrong yeah um
there's a bunch of under batteries and
well that's so weird that it's plugged
in it died it's still
or just still did that sometimes they
have recording limits of like
yeah all right we're also at 43 minutes
so yeah we just go main cam yeah
who cares dude yeah who cares honestly
if you made it this far yeah there's
like no chance that someone's watching
this 43 minutes and straight so if you
skip well maybe there is there's
definitely i mean
you'll do time stamps yeah right yeah so
maybe they'll like find one interesting
towards the end yeah that's what i was
doing to be honest so then let's um
let's do a real clickbaity title
for for this time how long should sex
last
yeah we'll just throw out like
titles we could do
um
big tit
latina so
now it's time for the segment where the
big titted latina walks yeah
yeah we got fat
fat tit milf
uh and i think that's enough that we can
name the segment this no matter what
yeah yeah we'll talk about fat milk fat
fat tip mill before we talk about what
whatever we're talking about before you
should just name your podcast like
something like that the fat tip milf
show the fat tip mill for like
just something yeah the the title of the
podcast should be clickbait like uh yeah
like trying to get a good one like just
you know
young black
yeah just call it black
the blacks podcast
people stroking the house like what the
who were these guys that would be so
sick if black had a podcast
just audio of hardcore yeah i mean i
guess it could be that or it could be
just like riley reid discussing racial
politics yeah that's something i'd i'm
very interested in i've always wondered
what her take is well she says the n
word so
riley reed if you look up her rapping
yeah
which is somehow more offensive than the
gang bang she makes
she like can you imagine like
that's funny she's a porn star she just
disgusting horrible acts and the worst
thing she's ever done is probably say
the n word don't you think she's earned
it
i get i mean i don't know i've never
earned it i'm not one to say i can't
speak on behalf of the black community
but i have a a friend of mine his name
is javaris but they've put her through a
lot yes
i mean she she seems to be enjoying it
oh yeah to be frank that's true i mean
there's the mascara and the crying but
that's all like they just i think they
like
the optics yeah
i think a lot of porn isn't real to be
honest yeah that's for us yeah yeah
that's for the that's for the nice
viewers at home yeah
so
so the fat to milf podcast yeah rolls on
brought to you by pornhub brought to you
by dude and we're still looking for some
sponsors so if if uh pornhub wants to
sponsor this or blue chew or a fat mel
for herself yeah
um i wonder if an individual only fans
has ever sponsored something
that would be pretty that would be
dude i don't know hold on like that
would financially viable though listen
to this
listen to this i'm listening
okay so my audience is
85 90 male yeah between
18 and 35 right yeah
if you were trying to get your only fans
off the ground
and you were already making money yeah
why not come to me i i start plugging
you in these videos so all of these
horny foods
hey this is my favorite only fans i
don't even have to look at it emily my
sweet girlfriend if you're listening i'm
not looking at it this is just a sponsor
i want yeah this is about money hey guys
yeah and i'll buy you something nice
with this too so it's fine
hey hey guys this is my favorite only
fans artist maybe we do a little teaser
artist
she's an artist
this that and the other dude there's 90
000 dudes that you can just get your
directly your tits in front of yeah i'm
willing to do it i have i'm looking for
sponsors me too honestly my instagram
is 92
92 mail nice let's go dude we're for the
[ __ ] boys we're the bros yeah we're
just literally for the dudes [ __ ]
like it's 92 dudes yeah i've always been
tempted to put on my story something
like too many girls and a screenshot of
my analytics but i'm like i don't i
don't even want to let dudes know like i
feel weird
like oh there's no
yeah yeah yeah my girlfriend she uh
i showed her that and she was like you
know i was kind of worried about like
girls dm'ing you from here i am not
anymore i'm like
you know these 18 to 35 they love edgy
humor that's what they're into these two
college age girls love pushing the
boundaries yeah
that's what they want to hear dude i i
can't they take jokes well
college age girl is like you know i love
patrice o'neill
that's what they love i love andrew
such a huge louie fan yeah yeah what i
listen to jre not the comic episode
i'm just gonna do the [ __ ] exercise
science stuff yeah that's what i want
yeah dude i'm getting yeah i'm i'm part
of the alt-right i listen to tim dylan
yeah yes
dude i love it i love it so much i love
the boys i'm not gonna lie i love the
brand i'm not gonna lie either i had a
time where my analytics was like 95
dudes and then i had like
that big video blow up about the will
smith reactions where it was more much
more public and less niche yeah and it
went from 95 dudes to like
95 dude so like 89 and now and i was i
was kind of heartbroken because
i don't want i didn't i don't know
you want women i want my demo no no you
want like i'm not saying like do
something that's insincere to try to
appeal to women but if you do something
and it does appeal to women do not stop
doing it yeah because they buy [ __ ]
that's um that's true they buy that's
true the boys don't buy anything that's
true like i don't buy anything i just
love the boys i'm like a fan of a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah and i don't buy anything
that's so true you know like i love yeah
uh
like some podcasts and i don't have any
patreons yeah but i should yeah i should
just support the homies dude i really
should have all the patreons if i think
about it yeah like there's things i'll
run out of episodes of podcasts and i'm
like damn it i think i wish there was
something for this yeah but i'm not
gonna spend five bucks a month now no i
bought one hoodie from a commute i
bought one merch item yeah and i've
bought one and then that's so funny i
bought a life rip sweatshirt and then
three days later crystalia got cancelled
i still wear it because you gotta
separate the art from the artist yeah
sure life still rips but what the [ __ ]
dude that's awesome you ruined your
merch and then i've subscribed to one
patreon which was tuesdays with stories
because that's because i made and like
they're an edit for them to post on
their patreon i wanted to see some
reviews about it yeah
reviews i mean they were pretty 50 50.
some of them they were mixed because
this is what this is the story of that
is like i i reached it because mark
norma had reposted some my edits before
so i made a few of just tuesdays with
stories that i didn't post myself that i
sent to them so they could just post
them privately
um still with like my intro my outro
which is which is fine but like
i'm not putting on my channel the only
place people could see this would have
been on their youtube right so then
they're like oh yeah that's cool and i
sent them the best of march oh like all
their podcast best clips on march it was
like a 35 minute thing and then like uh
just a regular edit 25 minute funny
tuesday of stories moments yeah and it
was designed for their youtube like the
thumbnail all the stuff for their
youtube but they decided because they
were running short on patreon content
one week to like upload both these for
their exclusive patreon content right so
on youtube that kind of thing completely
plays people are excited to see that
kind of stuff it's it's a lot of what
i've built my entire brand around right
on patreon some of the mixed reviews
were like hey man
we pay for this and we've already seen
all this yeah yeah yeah yeah and so like
i didn't know they were doing that for
patreon we didn't ever talk about that i
was just so hyped when they agreed to
feature oh that makes sense
and then as soon as i saw some of those
comments i was like oh yeah that makes
so much sense like right i wanted to be
offended but then i was like no dude
that makes complete sense
it's the critique of the the
but it would have played great on
youtube
what was posted you know
yeah yeah so that makes sense i mean
that that totally makes sense yeah
because i i could have got that but
that's the only time i've ever even
paid for a patreon and i think since
since then i i
didn't even react i want to get i'm
probably going to get gillis's to be
honest yeah because that's a podcast
that i just listened to everything
that's like one dollar right or did they
update i think it started off at one i
think
it recently stopped being a doll
it's like five dollars yeah because
there's it's he's like we're never we're
just making it a dollar and we're not
doing ads so then as he got bigger
there's clips of him being like [ __ ]
are we gonna have some [ __ ] ass yeah
yeah yeah yeah and now they just do ads
at the end and [ __ ] like they'll do a
whole episode be like oh [ __ ] we forgot
dude that's hilarious because you know
that like
like they're they don't they probably
don't even either they actually forgot
or they don't want to like
cloudy up their [ __ ] with ads yeah and
that sucks for the advertiser because no
oh yeah listening to that no i mean i
like yeah percentage-wise no one is yeah
but i'll watch
i'll listen to the end and then
listen to it i mean oh i've saw i've
also never bought an ad off of
like a a comedian that i like or like
hey support the show by using this link
the only thing i'd hello fresh i don't
like i don't know the only thing i might
actually buy is there are like nicotine
laws and just
like because i go i vape constantly and
then i go on a plane and like yeah i
have to fly for four hours and so you
know i'm gonna die because yeah nicotine
in four hours i might have to pop a
[ __ ] one of those laws that's a good
invention i didn't even know those yeah
they got lozenges gum we usually get
sponsored by them
it's uh lucy i think oh a ton of people
do lucy that's someone that i've been
i've been mean to maybe even reach out
dude dude if you want the boys dude like
yeah nicotine gambling and then yeah
only fans dude just vices
that's that's what dudes buy it you just
gotta remind them of what they're doing
yeah yeah just remind them of like their
problem yeah like of their habits that's
destroying their lungs or or their liver
but the cool thing about their walls is
that all of our vices we we kind of turn
into like isn't that kind of cool like
we could all do it together
that should start gambling dude dude
gambling's awesome i hate losing money
though i know but i want to put
sometimes
sometimes you can win it's so great to
win money
thank you
um
have you have you dabbled in gambling
before casino or yeah i mean i like
playing poker i'll play like home games
with my friends and spend at most forty
dollars right you know that's a big pot
depending on no no no like total like
buy-in is 20 and i lose oh and i buy it
oh they're 20. like we're just having
fun it's not
not money yeah i mean it's basically not
money okay it's like money enough to
where like oh my god damn i lost 20
bucks it's money enough to where people
aren't gonna screw around and bluff yeah
yes
it's like if you play with no money it's
meaningless it's like the minimum amount
of money to give it a bit of meaning to
be fun and for people to take it
seriously yeah and also like i've broke
ass friends who like twenty dollars is
like damn [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah um but i go
to a casino and i lose a hundred dollars
playing like one two limit poker or not
limit uh no limit poker
and i am fuming literally dude
i spent 90 minutes at a casino i'm like
i'm ready to kill someone yeah
yeah i
the the majority of time
and at least you want to kill someone
because majority of the time i want to
kill myself after leaving a casino no i
think i'd probably take a couple people
out with me yeah and then end it all i
that's that's such a better way to do it
because it should be at least the dealer
although it's not his fault but it
always seems like it is and they're
always so smug
and then the people around you who are
profiting or taking your cards yeah you
should take them out too i guess that
makes sense yeah that's right but
usually they're just better at poker
than i yeah like i was up for a while i
was playing good and then it's no limit
i make i made a really bad play
and because i think
i got cocky with it i had been getting
good hands that i got like a decent hand
not a winning hand
and i don't know i was just like well
i've been winning you know it's like
such a stupid mindset yeah and like i
had like i had like uh
i had like king eight right and it's
like i paired up my kings
which is not a great hand it's like hi i
got top pair with a [ __ ] kicker right i
don't know if you know poker stuff yeah
yeah top pair [ __ ] kicker and then the
guy at ace king and he was and in
hindsight i go yeah he was playing like
he had ace king i'm a [ __ ] idiot yeah
but suck
but a bad hand it's a bad hand like i
should have folded
after winning some poker hands though
it's almost bad to win a lot at the
beginning because then you think that
you can make something happen yes you
think you know how to play poker yeah
it's like no no no you got pockets
yeah that's what happened yeah i don't
know how to play poker but dude yeah
i'll get that's so funny i'll end up
with like three of a kind
and i'll be like like strategically like
putting in more chips and then obviously
when that hand with my friends and then
after that i'll be like yeah i'm
probably the best i'm like a poker guy
like i get probability like no you don't
yeah you don't know the odds you don't
you know what else you have right yeah
i'm like uh yeah i'm still like looking
up on google like which what what beats
what yeah yeah yeah is it flush better
than a straight i don't remember you
know but at the casino my game is
roulette and if it's not that then it's
blackjack but my problem is i'm going in
almost exclusively hammered
because when the bars close the casino's
open right so it's like last place to go
and this was way more at home in
cleveland because that's like it was
downtown and like here in tampa you have
to like take a it's like a 15-minute
drive to get to the casino to the casino
so i've only done that once here and i
think i actually i went in and then i
ended up throwing up the whole time i
think i gambled but but at home i would
uh it was we that's the place to go
afterwards and you'd always be just
hammered and be like we're all doing a
hundred dollar bet on the same thing
dude one time we all took out a hundred
bucks it was like 12 of my friends we
had a 1200 spin
and the whole night we were planning we
were planning this up and we were all
saying black we're black black black the
whole night black black black we get in
there we run into another one of my
buddies that we weren't even with in the
casino and he and his friend are also
doing a huge spin
and they're on red
they're less drunk than we are yeah and
we seem to believe them and they've been
at the casino and they've been winning
yeah oh yeah red red red switched around
switched it at red and we added there so
it's like a sixteen hundred dollar spin
yeah but it's only like a hundred bucks
each per person right but for some
reason all of us in our head think that
we're all gonna win
we all the cash we were staying in a
circle before we placed it and we all
passed the stack of cash around to one
another
and we placed it down
[ __ ] black ah dude you should have
gone black and that was like my mutual
friend so
everyone all my friend group was pissed
at me for for letting them kind of
change it yeah and they were like oh
we've been winning all day and i it it
was tough dude well if it would have
been red and you were if you would be
like no let's keep doing black we've
been chanting right exactly and then
it's red they're like what did you
listen to
yeah uh yeah that's a that's a norman
macdonald joke yeah where he talks about
uh he talks about roulette and uh he's
like you know you playing roulette you
put fifty dollars on red it comes black
and you're like [ __ ] i almost picked
that yeah it's like there's two options
yeah dude he has a bunch of great
gambling stuff but then it seems like
every time i try to do an individual bat
under because like for some reason my
brain's wired like
uh if i could just
i've thought this through something i
literally haven't have notebooks where
i've like written this plan out like
okay
a roulette plan a roulette plan that if
i start with this amount
500 and i could just win that that's a
lot to gamble but i could just win it
once like anything can happen once then
i have a thousand yeah and if i could
just win two in a row somehow i could
get to two thousand dollars and that'd
be crazy and then all i have to do is
win just one more and i made four
thousand dollars yeah all i have to do
is win three in a row like i've
literally written this i don't know why
you didn't remember my head but i just
right and it's like every time i've
tried to do something like that i've
never gone i think my biggest rude light
spin ever has been like 100
and i swear to god it's always green
it's always simple
i'd rather lose on the opposite color
than lose on green yeah green is insane
green is brutal i think i've played
roulette recently at like a casino
and i realize it's a lot more fun if you
don't just do colors
if you throw a bunch of random ones like
if you put a real asian guy moves yeah
if you put a dollar dude if you put a
dollar
on
eight yeah it pays
32
yeah and you only lose a dollar and you
only lose a dollar so you can make that
bet 32 times it's way more fun yeah you
play roulette for way longer yeah and
like you're more you're just as likely
to lose like it's all the same [ __ ]
anyway you're gonna lose right so you
might as well make more bets and then
like people have all these little goofy
strategies like there's no strategy but
you know like
shapes and stuff they make it it's way
more fun right you can split stuff you
can bet on the first third it seems just
so intimidating that's right
it's putting one dollar on the eight i
know
i know but like it's just how it looks
yeah or you can put it you've seen other
people do it when they have all the ch
and they're like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah between their fingers like jack
sparrow
[Music]
they make a little like celtic cross on
the [ __ ] thing and holy [ __ ] i didn't
know about the celtic cross
and they just lose 60 exactly oh [ __ ]
this guy's putting a swastika on the
board that's crazy i wonder what are the
odds on the swastika well
i feel like that might play yeah it does
especially on this podcast which like we
said
the alt-right pipeline
yeah i'm gonna think i think i might
start another podcast because it's
called the alt-right pipe yeah that i
think would play pretty well
yeah yeah yeah especially instagram
seems like they would have no problem
with those kind of clips right i mean
definitely youtube that's youtube's
bread and butter have you had any and we
can wrap this up maybe last question
have you had any issues um with that
kind of stuff like chicken pulled off
instagram or youtube
a little bit i've been demonetized
several times on instagram
because they were giving me some money
for stuff
and uh it was good money to be honest
like it was worth
i you know i thought it was like a fair
price you know what they were giving and
is that straight from instagram or like
an advertisement no it's instagram
there's like a bonus thing for reals
like
tick tock
like yeah it's like the creator fun for
tick tock but it's way better money okay
just wait tick tock fun sucks no it's
horrible it might as well i don't even i
don't even post on tech talk anymore no
i don't um
you get like four cents a day no no
you should ignore the money aspect and
just gain followers like yeah um and
that's kind of what i'm doing on
instagram now because i think they're
more strict with their content when they
know you're making money from it okay i
don't know i
i had three things demonetized and then
my viewers and followers went down like
pretty
drastically yeah like there's like a
three week period where i posted like 10
12 videos
and none of them got more than like the
followers i have so i was like what the
[ __ ] and then i stopped
being demonetized and now i'm up for
monetization again i've just been not
doing it and i've had two videos do
really really so it's like youtube where
it's like a partner program that you
apply to be mine tyson yeah well they
they uh they basically it automatically
pops up on your instagram
and uh but like right now you're
choosing not so i'm choosing not to do
it even though it's like you know if
something got views i could make like
maybe a thousand dollars a month which
is like a that's a lot of money like
that's your rent yeah that's more than
double my rent right yeah i have cheap
rent you know shouts out to uh you know
my landlord but uh
yeah so i'm just not doing that but yeah
i've had stuff removed for
i made a i was there's a crowd
it was just demonetized it was never
taken off tick tock i've had a million
things taken off
yeah tock tick tock tick tock guy like
i'm like
ma'am oh oh you know
are you gay and it's like gay get out no
i'm like what the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
chinese dude yeah
get out of here dude i don't even
understand why the chinese app is the
most like liberal [ __ ] dude chinese
people hate gay people
yeah right
like
i don't get like they should be the ones
pushing like why aren't they even yeah
they should be more they have their
conservative social values yeah
yeah yeah
has really fallen off
i miss the old china dude china used to
be so cool
but i had a i had an instagram post that
was like because i post people send in
the their 60 second stand up yeah
repost them or become collaborators with
them on that
just trying to like share lo like people
with less followers their bits whatever
and someone sent in a really funny joke
about like the punch line was like
something about this or that something's
not real or that's not real and his joke
is was about the holocaust yeah yeah a
clear joke i think everyone who's saying
that on stage is making fun of the
people that actually say believe that
because no one actually does right
it was really funny and it
in maybe like an hour it already like
hit went right up to like 10 000
views which for our instagram is
is pretty good because it's way less of
a following than our youtube obviously
because it's less established people and
that whatever right then it gets taken
down for violating community guidelines
yeah
which is fine i guess it's not fine but
it's fine but then it's like still
affected like it's like
that didn't go away still i still have
like a community like strike yeah yeah
no i got three of those yeah and i've
looked up [ __ ] on reddit and it's like
you're definitely shadow band bro now
like the shadow band stuff and it's like
then a few posts get like a thousand
views total where it's like okay well
now do i have to restart my whole
instagram it took so long to even get
this right where it is it just takes a
bit of time and it's like just don't
post or post things just for your
followers and just wait it out like yeah
as
like i want to like get the money again
but i also just don't want to be
i'd rather have more followers and no
money right yeah i don't care and those
followers can turn into money somewhere
down the road down the road dude like
you got to be able to do your art form
for people yeah yeah like let those
people like those people might buy a
ticket yeah i'd rather like a t-shirt or
something yeah i'd rather just get you
know a ticket thing you know i'd rather
them come see me
than make five hundred dollars a month
on instagram yeah give a [ __ ] like yeah
whatever it's six grand a year that's
going to be taxed at 48 percent or
whatever the [ __ ]
because you know whatever i got to sign
a w-9 for instagram and [ __ ] which is
cool but yeah um
yeah it's just stupid it's definitely
i i i agree with that that's definitely
the way to go yeah just more followers
like it's so much more valuable than
than six grand in the years like who
cares well hopefully we get more
followers out of this um and and you as
well thank you for watching if you're
still watching i'm sure you are after
the big titted milf yeah dude this is
like
podcast so we're signing off from the
big ticket podcast uh thank you for
doing this
um course maybe we can do it again soon
you're definitely very local and i
can't
what a compliment
you're definitely very local definitely
very local and i can't imagine anyone
thinking that this was a bad episode so
i yes thank you
[Music]
you